[Music]
delighted to say we're joined now by
jeremy hunt he's the longest serving
health secretary in england he's now
chairs the select committee
and is a conservative back venture
jeremy welcome to the program
good afternoon let me ask you this
clearly the roll out of the vaccine is
both a
a vital medical imperative in dealing
with corvette
and it's very important as we've been
saying politically for mr johnson and
his
government what will be the challenges
what are the biggest challenges you
think
the government faces in getting this
role out to 13 million
of the most vulnerable before february
is out
well it is a massive logistical exercise
but we have one big advantage over the
problems that we had with
track and trace and the the contact
tracing and the centralized testing
laboratories last year
which is that we're not using new
infrastructure to do this we're using
our existing network of gps
supplemented by new centers that are
being set up but a lot of it will be the
existing
infrastructure and i'm actually quite
optimistic that the nhs will rise to the
challenge i think that
the numbers that have been done so far
are actually very impressive
to have got to more than a million
already and i think the
the challenge we've got is actually not
on the vaccine rollout it is the
question of whether the nhs is going to
fall over
because the health service journal is
saying that
within two weeks london will run out of
intensive care
capacity but we know from previous
lockdowns with this
virus there's a three-week delay between
doing something big like a lockdown
and it actually feeding through into
hospital admissions
and that is too long when it comes to
london
so um i think it's going to be a very
very nail-biting
next few weeks is is it too late
to do anything about that hospital
capacity now is it
inevitable that in the next couple of
weeks we'll get to where you described
okay
is there emergency action that can be
taken there is and i don't actually
think we will get to the point where uh
someone who needs an intensive care bed
doesn't get one because the nhs at the
moment is
will be scrabbling around frantically to
try and source those extra beds whether
from the private sector whether from
neighboring trusts and i think they'll
do it but what i don't think will happen
is that we will
i don't think we'll be able to avoid the
knock-on effects on things like
cancer care maybe some people
who might have been sent to intensive
care or borderline case
in previous times won't get sent this
time
who knows you know the outcome might not
be as good for that person so i'm afraid
the kind of knock-on effects that we saw
in the first
lockdown in terms of the impact on other
nhs care
will be very severe the government has
been widely criticized over the months
for its handling of the whole covert
crisis
every government's been criticized but
mr johnson's government has come in for
more than most is is the vaccine it's
get out of jail card
does that is it the does the vaccine
overwhelm all the other criticisms
i think it could i i'd rather agree with
james's analysis
just now um we were too slow to go into
lockdown
too slow to adopt uh test and trace as a
methodology
um but we have been the best in the
world
at approving vaccines and in terms of
distributing them just behind israel so
better than any other comparably sized
country and i think
we can say with a lot of pride it wasn't
just the brilliance of british science
and of course the fisa vaccine wasn't
developed in this country but the
obviously the oxford astrazeneca one i'm
going to put the word oxford in even if
nicola sturgeon won't
uh it was and i think that may turn out
to be the best vaccine
as it happens um but actually government
decisions
i mean matt hancock uh set up the
vaccine task force with kate bingham
you know that had controversy in the
early days he made a big
play gambling on pre-buying
quantities huge quantities of different
types of
vaccines and those gambles paid off
and that was a ministerial decision and
he should get a lot of credit for that
so
i think if this works out people will
say well we had a very tough pandemic we
didn't get it all right but we got some
things
very right and if we're the first
country to get back to normal
that will be a very very big fill up for
the government
i think most people regard this as a
national effort almost like a wartime
effort to rule out this
vaccine and it has to be all hands to
the deck that's
understandable so what do you make then
of when
we hear that public health england says
it won't work on sundays
i do think that's extraordinary i'm a
little bit hesitant
to to to pile in until i actually know
that's true
but if it is true and if i had been a
minister i would have been
sending that recommendation right back
and saying what on earth are you talking
about this is absolute nonsense
and has the government i mean it has
seemed that
time and again the government has been
behind the curve i think it's a
criticism
you have made of them too particularly
when it comes to lockdown
is that because of mr johnson's kind of
natural libertarian instincts that he's
always been reluctant to do
what he's ended up having to do as we've
seen this week
i think it may be that and in some ways
i think that because of those instincts
when we do finally do a lockdown there's
quite a lot of public support for it
because
people do recognize this is not
something the government has
rushed into and i think there are
genuine issues
i mean i think we should have gone in
earlier and actually even this week i
think we should have made the decision
last week because i'm not really sure
what data was
only available on monday that we
couldn't have seen on thursday or friday
of last week
but nonetheless uh he you know on monday
he had a meeting on monday afternoon he
made the decision we went
bang into lockdown from the following
morning that is a whole lot quicker than
the
speed that decisions were made at the
start of the pandemic
where are we equipped to deal with this
i mean clearly not when you look at
what's happened but
you were sexually safe for health when
this operation
cygnus the the pandemic war game uh
was carried out and it was a very
extensive
war game and i read quite a lot about it
but it wasn't
for covert type pandemic it was
it was the wrong war game wasn't it
that's exactly
the point i mean all the recommendations
that were made to ministers
following that pandemic were implemented
and there were some that were very
useful for this pandemic for example
drafting the emergency powers
legislation that was a pretty important
piece of work that came out which we
sadly did have to put into
practice but if you look through that
report
there is not a mention anywhere of
testing not once
and that kind of sums up that we were
not just in this country but across the
whole of europe and america
there was this group think that pandemic
equals flu pandemic and
you know looking back on it you have to
say
you know we had sars in 2002 mers in
2014
they happen to be in other parts of the
world but
i think it's very important that we set
up structures now
to make sure that that group think of
which i was part
doesn't take hold going forward well
let's go forward a little bit finally uh
jeremy hunt uh from what you've been
saying
it seems possible that if we get the 13
million roll out to the most vulnerable
groups
by the end of february we will after
that begin to see
the death rate and the case numbers
begin to fall we can then get more a lot
more than 13 million
and it may not be pie in the sky to
think
that sometime after easter which is very
early this
year in april there could be
not an event that's a return to
normality
but the beginnings of a process that
heads towards
some semblance of normality well i'm an
optimist and i've booked a family
holiday for the summer half term which
is the first week of june so um
i very much hope that uh i don't have to
get another of these bloody vouchers
that the airlines give you when you
cancel your
your tickets but i um i do think there
is a lot of risk
and i think we've just got to recognize
the most important
thing is something we're going to hear
in the next two weeks
which are the results of the test which
they're doing public health england are
doing important down
at the moment which say whether the
vaccine works
against the new kent strain
and then about a week after that we
should hear whether the vaccine works
against the south african strain
and that is the bit of information that
i am really
waiting for before i start banking
everything on easter
[Music]
you